greetings from podcast Ville it's the
Church of what's happening now brought
to you by and we're walking on them back
my favorite me on these Valentine's Day
is right around the corner and love is
in the air that means it's perfect time
to look that special someone right in
their little baby blues and tell them
how much you care by saying those three
special words match my undies that's
right
Mandy's has matching underwear for you
and your girl that's got a little
special prints on them to get you in the
mood for Valentine's Day and I'm saying
but if you don't have a special someone
me and these has something even better
if you got a dog or a cat they can match
them too so it's for your little buddy
bands bandanas made from their signature
micromo deal material so your dog can
look just like you listen they're man's
best friends for a reason plus man these
[ __ ] [ __ ] got everything they got
socks loungewear joggers robes slippers
even baby clothes honest to god right
now I got me on these on I wear me
undies still till this day they're the
most comfortable [ __ ] up underwear
out there and I tell you this with the
all sincerity in my heart
do yourself a favor right now go to me
on these calm slash Joey and get 15% off
and free shipping on your first purchase
blush you get me on these hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee I'll
enjoy what's that 15 percent off free
shipping hundred-percent guarantee me on
these calm / Joey Jo ey one more time
for the cheap cheap seats me undies calm
/ Joey 15 percent off with your first
purchase plus we're gonna give you free
shipping all right and slip into
something more comfortable
like me I'm these no more those [ __ ]
tighty whities shoes like a [ __ ]
jerk-off anyway but K quickly what's
that where the [ __ ] you been you're
beautiful I love those hair extensions
or no that's my hair looks beautiful
long oh I love you thank you I was I was
just working out and then you called me
here we are I called because that was it
was just one of those couple days man
and I love them but we have the best
can we just well it looks like we just
need to pick me up us do it I just need
to pick me up on what the month end not
strong it's a rough week in LA you know
you were talking about gay bars before I
will get into the game we moved here and
we didn't have a kid so when we moved
here one night my wife and I was sitting
in nobody invited us to a Super Bowl
party okay and we said let's take a walk
around the neighborhood we walked around
the name but we walked into this [ __ ]
bar and we're sitting there and the game
turns on and they got people bringing
food all these guys are bringing food
like cakes and for the Super Bowl the
Super Ball they've got a pool table and
they had all the food on top of there
and after about 20 minutes in maybe 30
minutes I don't know I'm having a
tequila or whatever the [ __ ] on my habit
I probably got an edible of me mm-hm and
all of a sudden my wife goes you do know
we're in a gay bar besides the chubby
lesbian over there with the military
haircut and the flag hanging see the
alag as the tarp and over the thing and
again I didn't get get up and leave
I had a [ __ ] great sure I ended up
watching the Super Ball I hate some food
one guy recognized me from the store he
was an open mic er I'm surprised you're
even here you know [ __ ] my wife was he
he looked at me we're sure that type of
[ __ ] til there but then I didn't know I
don't you know I don't know nothing
about the gay culture yeah more than we
met Eric and then you have a gay friend
the Chinese guy or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah Kremlin Korea you guys are telling
us this [ __ ] like if you want to be a
conservative gay guy like if you want to
be like you know the people that buy we
know when they you know in the Boston
Red Sox go to the World Series right
yeah and people buy Boston that's oh she
and their fair weather those are the gay
people and go to Santa Monica Boulevard
yeah you're right what's hardcore they
come to the valley come to the vows yeah
I didn't discuss it's true I didn't
discover now there's no bar called a
mouthful no okay every moment is about
mouth a bar for
that's your friend your gay friend you
talk about okay all I know is I have a
gay uncle and his husband who live up
the street from here and after so I was
taking them out to a gay bar after I met
up with you one night you're like you
got to take him to the mouthful I heard
there's a teepee in the back they get
their dick sucked or something like that
yes
yeah my uncle and me spent a whole night
trying to find this play like googling
mouths full Los Angeles West it's not
there's no place but there's a place
like that
I think the mouthful is like not the
real name of the place they keep
switching them it's which name I says no
the gay bar that I went to here in the
ballet so now which one did you go - I
went to the one around the corner of
Burbank bull the bullet one that's well
known before the bullet which has a flag
outside that's the one where I got
robbed there's one on Burbank bull after
Vineland and all that [ __ ] yeah I
dropped that record
it's a big one that's the bullet oh yeah
that's the bullet that's the one with
three room now let me tell you what
happened okay right let me tell you what
happened that used to be a Mexican
restaurant across the street Liz yelling
but know that for that one bullet used
to be like a Mexican oh yeah teeny and
restaurant like a and all of a sudden
what they did was they took this gay bar
over here and they switched them that's
why they started selling tacos in front
of their agent that place is that crazy
go over there dude so I dropped that
require from there one night I knew that
was the bullet bar but I knew that or
somebody in my circle has mentioned let
me tell you what this game barbarism
i'ma tell you what the gay bar is you
have to go but if they realize dannion
and after two or three blocks you gotta
make a left and you go into a
neighborhood and it's like warehouses
and recording studios and back there you
park cuz one night I want to do Eddie
Bravo's podcast it was there his podcast
at 11:00 yeah and we came out
me we were slowly you couldn't smoke in
the studio this has to be five six years
ago so I'm putting all these pieces
together now and at the corner it was a
hobbit it was it's on the corner it
sound like a dead end type Street nobody
knows they're there the purple lights
are there there must have been 20 guys
outside with their [ __ ] hats on and
then when I got in the car that night to
leave I said let me see what the [ __ ] it
is you can't you and it's like it's a
weird neighborhood in North Hollywood
it's half residential but a couple
warehouses whatever it's the same oh
this is why I thought that was the
mouthful it's really it with John Evan
has his jiu-jitsu Triana back there
across the street is a strip club that
nobody talks about I hear if you go in
there with a hundred bucks don't around
the world you'll I don't know what the
name is that mean what's around the
world don't look at balls in your
[ __ ] this sucks but it's my woman
who's got shot twice when I used to go
trained jiu-jitsu with John Hammond I
would see guys going in there for lunch
time when I asked John about that one
time I go professor do you ever go over
there after class at night and he goes
that's not the kind of strip club but
you're wrong there's two cuz I always
went to strip clubs
I go to strip clubs on now what do you
hear about the circles in the valley
highs Lee said he went to one where
there was videos yeah that's the one I
thought you were talking about yeah the
gay bar yes the gay bar with that right
there's two in the valley that I've been
to they're both you got to understand
like for the people listening like most
of us go to gay bars where like straight
girls go cuz guys don't flirt with you
but the gay guys love you and
everything's happy and bubbly and
rainbows these are like if if like the
seediest gay dudes like a game mob ran a
club that's outfit you have to even go
down the one you're talking about with
the videos yeah you have to go down a
little side alley thing to walk in and
then there's
rooms if they think you're straight or
if you're me they didn't even what like
they wouldn't let me in the back room
the back room is like the sexually
everybody's [ __ ] I think that's your
teapot I think he might I think you
might have gone to his side one cuz the
one that we're talking about the bullet
you just go right on Burbank and they're
they they they let me right in
did they charge you a cover no but it
was an off-night after I've only went
once wait but there's this a woman two
video screens in a porn playing it
that's the same one I wanna Burbank but
either by the Chinese by our old office
order they probably didn't let you in
the back somebody's gotta tell you about
the bags I know I went to the back with
the tent I didn't go in the tent you
went all the way back there yeah they
totally gave you a gay past they would
not my buddy took me on a tour I was
with two gay dudes and a guy was very
like you never think at a gay bar a
guy's gonna step to you and be mean cuz
you know that happens at straight bars I
love it I had the best experience ever
II was so nice to be there he took me
around it was it was raining so I don't
think anyone was in the tent that night
but I was so good to see the tent it
looks it looks like one of those
homeless tents under the bridges it's
like it's barely men's ass and by dead
sperm on the floor oh because the Jews
just comes out of their mouth I don't
but I I know you hate Yelp but they have
the best Yelp really all right let's
read the review they have they have this
is what goes on and guys like we don't
know this should exist so when I found
out about all these stories and then my
gay neighbor and his stories I was like
there's a secret of secret from nation
dude there's like a secret island of my
luck goes on in the valley my gay bestie
he'll do like you know some people have
they like party for a week and then take
two or three weeks and not do anything
at all and then we'll do like a bender
he does that with [ __ ] dudes and it's
the funniest I mean we were on the road
together at 2:00 in the afternoon he's
like hey do you mind if I go up the
street this guy on Grindr he wants to
hook up I'll be back in like an hour
I'm like you just trying to stranger to
go [ __ ] like an appointment he's like
yeah but I'll be back
then he comes back then later he's like
I have a date I'm like what he's like in
an hour
he went on to [ __ ] dates before the show
and another one after the show I can't
tell if this is the one wait this is in
Santa Clarita
this is in Burbank oh my god just
knowing that leave the math did you
review this I
they had a photo I love this I love all
this [ __ ] I grew up in New York was
eccentric they were doing this when you
weren't allowed to be gay New York when
I was a kid you couldn't tell you could
be gay underground bars and that's where
we go I would go to one in Guttenberg
New Jersey to get coke [ __ ] be doing
disgusting stuff in there I was that guy
I know that guy sorry oh my god I'm Alan
wait let's read some of the reviews yeah
just visited from Han Han just say yes
to everything that's the best just out
for a tenner oh my god Oh is there gay
bars ladies and gentlemen I am learning
something just say yes to everything the
staff the bartenders even the patrons
all great all smiles all loving right
needed is the part of town I can only
hope this is all the wall stays that's a
gay guys my regrets be generous with the
use of adjectives but I'd take the
bullet over though we all join hands
down no hesitation come on by and see
the valley vibes are all about I wanted
to go but as soon as I walked on the
sunlight the place need read their
cigarette smoke how is that legal you're
getting [ __ ] in the ass what do you
scroll it I've been prolonged he helped
hiatus can you go a little down more you
know I'm blind the other way dive bar go
up more there you go
I prolong you ups I hear this because I
found this so this thing strategy around
this mob like even and their user base
consists of goons threatening to use the
platform whatever the [ __ ] when you see
the menu Brendan on your fashion Nova
outfit notwithstanding I simply adore
this place make no mistake about it this
place is a dive someone Ralph's inside a
wild back and going and smell like
throw-up for a salad in an inch of
putrid Bud Light and prep scented urine
you can live on your brisket fantasies
and get carmel crunchy smoke in the semi
covered patio but the character topknots
this would want a dying breed of gay
bars
everyone now wants fancy cocktails and
they'll drink by themselves tucked away
in a corner while thumbing through the
hook-up action drug drag performers this
place has a run raunchy old-school skin
flicks and locals that actually strike a
conversation with you as a special night
that caters to many whims and
subcultures in the LGBT community under
bear is a personal favorite to auger
posit men it has some of the nicest
bartenders of them at the gay bar and a
decent Sunday beer break why you may be
hard-pressed of of sobbing a beverage
you had a cleat chichi bar this place is
legit and there's always parking around
the neighborhood that's the dive bar
welcome all the cheap drinks awesome
place to just have a drink and chill who
wear some nice and special events and
there's a cover also adult movies play
on the screen this one a few gay bars
and the valley would probably the best
the staff is beyond friendly and will
greet you with a smile and stick pull
and this neighborhood bought great
events band nights with soul music
Sunday's drag Brenda bingo
movie nights even pj underwear it's a
great scene without the WeHo attitude
went for under
night for the first time I will be back
under bear night we got to look this up
still the best leave I let the gay bar
in the entire Los Angeles area intimate
friendly and full of good times keeps
growing you miss the best part
I don't look for the underbarrel night I
will be back had so much fun hot guys
yummy shots also the tent weight but
here's the best I went on a trans night
and I've never gotten hit on more in my
life not at a straight line to trans
tonight trans night is just it's because
the name the Kate without offending any
no no that was what they called it
translate it was like the performers
there were dancers and they were all
transgendered dancers I don't know if
they were post-op pre-op what but I just
thought it was interesting that I got
hit on more than I ever have at a
straight bar a sports bar and I was like
I wonder if they think I'm trans or if
they think I'm a girl like I wanted to
ask people but I didn't want to offend
anyone so I just didn't but I've never
gotten more action like I left feeling
like a million bucks I mean I got but I
felt great about it got a blood guy was
a big [ __ ] dick what would you do if
he had tits and he took you home I had
like a 12-inch [ __ ] if I didn't notice
the tits before I got there you mean you
know he's transgender depends what he
looks like
no but he's saying I would I wouldn't if
I saw the tits right away I wouldn't
probably go home with her because I
think it was a girl and I only go home
with girls when it's like a guy girl
scenario this is it this is the perfect
combination the burger with a hot guy
and then it turned out he was he had
little boobs little ones I didn't notice
I mean at that point I'd probably be
drunk enough I priced I'll do it if I
was turned out it depends but if I go
home with a stranger I'm pretty
desperate in the first place how's it
been with you have a boyfriend year or
is this no boyfriend I have a crush no
boyfriend but I did have my first ever
real legit one-night stand in Phoenix
oops I shouldn't said where it was a
caveat though that he said when he came
in I said that wasn't a football player
but the only reason I said that is cuz
that I
you like shouldn't count because that's
like an accomplishment you know you know
what I mean they'll be like if you
hooked up with like a like Victoria's
Secret model that doesn't count as a
one-night stand that's like a look at
that but I mean you wouldn't call that a
one-night stand you'd call that like a
bucket list goal and I've only hooked up
Lee anyway you put up with whole [ __ ]
focus no I have not phone number but I
don't hook up with them they just have
your phone number because they want
talking about I'm surprised you haven't
sucked Antonia Browns dick I'm losing
his wife no I got gonna be Kate right
now you [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] I know papi
I love you when he told the kid papi I
love you cops I'm surprised Tony O'Brien
I was so I was actually you should
[ __ ] look them down on a blind date
we want to Pauly Shores friends and you
can't do on a blind date with Antonio
Brown I mean he's got a little bit of
money left you pick it all it's not a
blind date because I know what he looks
like a handsome dude he's got burnt
black feet does he burnt his feet in the
[ __ ] and he got frostbite frostbite
in a [ __ ] non cryotherapy when there
was no socks on which listen I go in
then I'm scared I gotta with the [ __ ]
ice up I couldn't even go to freeze
because I couldn't put my chubby [ __ ]
hamstring sock it's gotta be above the
hamstring it's gotta be above the
Achilles tendon because you're Kelly's
ten little freeze in the cryotherapy how
he went in there barefoot is beyond me
that is the guy that you're looking for
a long time I'm not gonna lie no we have
somebody wanna do better Joey just got
off house arrest yeah so hardened how
sad is it that like I asked a guy the
other day that I'm like just talking to
I said I said I only have one question
have you ever been to jail for hitting a
woman and he said no but then I was
thinking like how sad it is that that's
like where my love life
that that's like my that's my you know
bare minimum for what I need out of guys
back through this hookup how do they go
down okay I never hooked up on the right
Ole Miss on a [ __ ] detail here cuz I
got an investigator's okay
I never hook up you know I've hooked up
on the road but even when I have it's
always like on the second or third time
I meet the guy like I make these poor
guys actually like it's almost like they
have to date me to even hook up on the
road they come two nights or three
nights this was the first ever like we
did the show Sunday night after the show
we were planning Foley to drive back to
LA the car was packed we were like we
gave the condo keys back we were leaving
and then what happened was there's guy
in the audience of my show who I thought
was cute and that never happens we
started talking and we had a mutual
friend so then I said to Adan my opener
I said listen I kind of wanted to talk
to this guy a little longer can we just
do one drink down the street half an
hour at the Blue Martini and we'll
bounce and he's like okay we go into the
Blue Martini there's a private party for
some kind of like R&B hip hop group and
it was just packed with like hot young
black dudes and you know it's not like I
only like like you know I kind of like
black dude so when I walked in and said
there was a guy or well yeah I wasn't
there with a guy I was a group he had us
whole group of friends but when we came
in I talked to him for a little while
the guy I came in with and then I
started to get distracted by other
people and then Aidan's like hey Kate we
should probably get out and get going
and I said Aidan I think I'm gonna [ __ ]
somebody here I never do that I've never
done it and he was like do you feel like
you really need it and I was like I kind
of do it's been like a month I'm really
horny which means two hours
no Joey it have been like a month the
last guy last night I called legally how
much money we got tell me the truth I'm
thinking opening up a restaurant with
you and Steve Simone whatever number you
told me had thrown it's it's ten
thousand more I don't lie about this
stuff it's not that you're wise you know
you never get you know I don't I show
you I'll tell you
you know that I told you everything I
really hadn't the last guy it was the
guy that I put the one-night stand to
happen I mean that's what's crazy it's
been so [ __ ] weird now with me
tooling and how you have to be careful
with people you know we say these
stories on the road not to interrupt you
or anything that's okay we had this
situation a couple weeks ago that I
thought of a guest on the podcast a
former guest of ours on the podcast not
a bad guy
musician gets accused of dating a 16 or
17 year old girl
I read the article the first thing I
remember was you really want me to tell
you I remember thinking about Paris
Hilton on David Letterman she doesn't
interview on David Letterman when she
was hot but she was getting into trouble
this Adams yeah yes yes ago yes and she
goes so when did you start being a party
divas humans I was basically 14 I'm sure
she was she goes well what was she doing
she goes I would sneak out of my window
at night and go to all the top clubs in
the city you know let me ask you a
question Kate let's be honest amongst us
as human beings I mean not me cuz it
never happened to me one time it
happened but when you're 15 Kate do you
go out to [ __ ] a 15 year old guy we know
when are you I was on a mission
everything I had maybe like four years
old it yeah your freshman you go for the
seniors and after that it's kind of
weird you know so I'm thinking of these
allegations that he dated it through
high school I'm thinking about Don
Johnson marrying Melanie Melanie
Griffith when she was 17 I'm thinking
about the 70s when it was rumored that
if right now in the 70s you could
actually charge Jimmy Page with
statutory rape because he dated a
fourteen-year-old that he took with him
on the road that's a little you know he
was on the state's you know if a girl
you know what if she looks
18 me I mean I have a daughter so I get
it I get the whole thing
but this is something that you know
right now we have it we're going through
some tough times now you got a watch but
you know what little it's more
entertainers if you want me to [ __ ]
sit here as a comedian and tell you that
in 28 years especially on those [ __ ]
Tribble runs let me tell you something
those triple runs are pure it's a three
week sex run
yeah there's no way I'm sorry I lied to
you about there I'm telling you right
now I am NOT a good-looking guy and I'm
Tom know I'm talking about dating a
younger woman I'm talking about this
comedians here when you want a triple
run I will send you on a triple run then
you will come back and go [ __ ]
Billings money I've seen it I've seen it
because when I would go on the road with
Jack and even even like the local host
not to be a dick to say like a hoshin
but I mean like if you're onstage in a
comedy club after the show the audience
girls that are there that are single and
buzzed will flirt with you it doesn't
matter what you look like oh my god it
doesn't matter what you did I have
stories that upon stories oh I've seen
it it's crazy and you sit there and go
how did this even happen I'm not even a
good-looking guy what would happen if I
look like George Michael I would have
[ __ ] everybody and it would be all
you had to do in those days Lee was do
the triple gig kill kill which you don't
even really have to kill and you go to
the bar and afterward we'll be ladies
night that the show has to end the tent
totally you were in Billings Montana oh
there's nothing else bar closes at 2:00
there's only two bars Nutella this
ladies night there's 90 women there and
there's a certain type of woman that has
a fetish that she will take you home Lee
light your [ __ ] on fire suck your
dick let her come out of faith and next
day she goes to work and you leave
she'll give you a number you call it a
bum number what that means is she has
the fetish that she just likes to [ __ ]
and move on I don't even know if it's
like even a fetish as much as because
this time when I did it oh I can tell
you the secret to how the guy got laid
because like people can use this which I
can't believe it worked on me and
hindsight I must've been drunk as [ __ ]
we're at the club and there's a guy
that's trying to talk to me the whole
he was totally cock-blocking me and by
the way Aiden my gay bestie kind of
[ __ ] me because when he left to go
back to the condo
he handed the keys to this guy and he
said can you make sure she gets back
safe so I was soul cock-blocked right so
this guy won't leave me alone and
there's this guy I see over short of
this checking me out and he's hot and so
I keep like some kind of smiling at him
hoping he'll come over so he waits for
the dude that's watching me to go to the
bathroom he comes up he's like is that
your guy I'm like no he's totally cocked
bugging me like I kind of wanna get out
of here like this sucks and he's like
let me get your number he's like I'm
here with some buddies we're gonna leave
soon I'll text you he walks off then my
dude that's watching me comes back and
the bar starts closing down so he's like
okay it's time to go so I didn't know
what to do because I wanted to go home
with the other guy or at least go juice
after party something so I made up a
story oh god he's gonna listen to this
or whatever I made up a story that my
firm was gonna come pick me up
and we were gonna go out to some
after-party so I was like you can just
give me the condo keys and take off and
so he did and then I looked for the
other guy and he was talking to another
chick and the chick in him were all like
about to leave together
so then I was like [ __ ] if they leave
that what am I gonna do I'm like I gotta
get him it became an instant competition
he was brilliant because what happened
is then it kind of walked up as a hey
just want to say goodbye and he was in a
group wasn't just him and a chick but he
turned around he's like oh you're
leaving I'm like yeah he's like oh I'll
go with you I only walked up to him she
was with a chick if I hadn't seen him or
if he'd been like just with boys I
probably wouldn't have but he was with
another chick it made me like oh [ __ ] I
kind of she's hot maybe he's hot
maybe I should bang this guy so I get
him we leave we take an uber and here's
what's funny I was trying to go to after
party so I was nervous to go home with a
stranger
but the uber ride around he was so like
nice and funny like first of all he
wanted food more than you wanted sex he
was like I really want to get like
Carl's jr. like she just wanted food so
bad I'm like this guy's safe like no any
guy
wants a burger more than wants to [ __ ] a
stranger is like not that desperate to
get laid not gonna rape you right so we
go he buys me food then we go to his
place and he was just he was really
respectful he's kind of distant he asked
me a lot of questions he stayed on kind
of farther away from me until he kind of
like until I felt safe and then he was
like you know I don't expect anything
you can go anytime if you don't want to
stay the night like don't feel pressure
whatever that's the move that's the word
I told my girlfriend yesterday I go
there was this guy I went home with once
and I literally was in bed with him
making out and I said look this is only
like the second time we've hung out I
just I don't think I want to sleep with
you yet I kind of like you and he goes
hey I want you to do whatever makes you
want to stick around for a long time if
that means we wait we wait he's like I
just think you're amazing so whatever
whatever makes you want to stay and I
[ __ ] him some guys is like doesn't
slick it's when you got it you know the
whole sex game is such a psychological
[ __ ] game at the end of the day it
really is like that whole I'm happy I'm
out of it
it's embarrassing which one the way you
just mentioned a hole no that one's not
because that's a person that I'm
actually like still friends with and
well we we made out a few times after
that but we never had sex again
well because you don't really do the
apps that much right because that's like
I've had probably more one-night stands
than relationships I would guess well
guys get more one-night stands off those
apps I think I don't know I mean I could
never hit up a dude on an app and I
gotta have the chemistry that's why I
got to talk to you for a little what do
you think the girls on the apps they
always say they want a relationship I go
expecting a relationship like expecting
it to be a date at least and then like
you hook up like the first of the second
time and then you never hear from them
my thing is that's weird is even with
the NFL guy by the way there's only one
even with the NFL guy like I when I meet
these guys I make them talk to me for
like two hours I got to feel like I know
him a little before I can follow though
let's go back to the one last
so now he says Papa buy you can we what
do you do you take his shirt off that's
cute I kind of liked him but here's the
other thing I started to like him okay
he has kids he's divorced he's a sweet
guy I like there were things about him I
liked he's not in the business he works
in like corporate America and so then I
started thinking maybe I could date this
guy like he's Phoenix isn't that far so
then I was like I'll just stay the night
and he's real hot and then I'm like and
if we don't date you know who cares
I'll just he seemed safe what was the
next move so then we start making out
and then you know I was the one that was
like you want to go upstairs we were
making out for so long weeks he ever
gonna take me upstairs I had to do
everything that was one thing I liked
guys to make the move and there's been a
lot of guys that I've gone out many
times with and they never made the move
because they were [ __ ] and it
never happened and I would've probably
[ __ ] him but in this case I was just
really horn I don't know I'm getting to
that age I'm horn it's like and I'm not
saying this like people always talk [ __ ]
like Kate just talked about sex I'm just
saying cuz my age it's how do you know
would you don't make me tell that there
you say harlot oh yes it's it's mmm I
spilled some so upset I'm an old man now
but I've been through you know we I've
lived all those years and I'll never
forget sleeping with women my age for a
while I was 21
no lying to you guys till I was 19 and
then when I was 19 I went to basalt
Colorado I've been that been two girls
moved there next to us and they put me
on ER they were sisters
Walt was 29 and the other one was 26
they were Italian girls from know
walking and I could look you straight in
the face Kate at 19 I'm like and there
was fly just I just knew that it was it
was only four houses on that block
oh you mean were connect
not because of their age because you
just don't I [ __ ] your neighbors they
were both yeah yet they were both
beautiful I mean just looking at them to
a boat honestly I think it's probably
the best they came over and knocked on
the door and said hi were me me and Lili
we moved in next door with four guys
that are [ __ ] killers okay from North
Bergen New Jersey one guy could [ __ ]
anything and I'll never forget these
girls used to come over every night at
6:00
I swear to God I don't know how they did
this fault
outside outside and then another woman
would come home with my friend she was
married happily married and she would
come over to our house every night every
night at six o'clock we would have four
or five women watching TV with us and
nobody would hit on these women it was
like we had become a first call it was
the weirdest I have that with people to
29 year old I would look at her and she
would say things to me like you need to
get a girlfriend she would just say
little cuz otherwise she would no no no
no it was the weirdest thing like I
never hit on her that's why I never
looked at it like that in fact if
anything I liked a younger sister a
younger sister I saw her sunbathing one
day and she had the hairiest [ __ ] I had
you love that it was coming you want
like an afro go down through the shorts
at that time I was 19 I was very easily
impressed how much hair would you like a
love down there like you want like had
like a couple of Pew sticking out of the
bikini type pair like yeah Italian I
knew what it would smell I'm sorry I
mean say you know you know I mean she
was a beautiful girl and this is just
what happens this is what happens in
life I control myself
we were neighbors for months my choice
do you have and
one day I started talking to the older
sister at night she was a liquor check
she worked she was a whiner expert she
was not at night she was 29 her and I
had nothing to bond
yeah but I think I hit the bag outside
and she would pull up at a quarter to
ten and then she would bring me like an
apple and stuff like that we would talk
and she would smoke a cigarette talk to
me and she would say I wish I could date
a guy well I always became friends and
that went on for two months and then we
all went to Glenwood Springs and I saw
her in a bikini and I was like if I
thought the younger sister was hot oh
yeah what do we got here nice and I was
like you know what I gotta be cool but
she also cut head that was her thing she
cut hair so I needed a haircut so she
had cut my hair and one day we'll have
the conversation I see you and I go you
off tonight
she was jacked off I give you ten bucks
you may act that she's like absolutely
come over a sister was upstairs Tia Leah
something's coming back to me now this
hot woman is cutting my hair we're just
brewing that heck boobs like push my
back she had great boobs had great boobs
I would keep my hands to my side I was
embarrassed I was kind of nervous and
she asked me what what is the point with
you why don't you at least go out and
try to get a girlfriend go what is it
with you and me getting a [ __ ] girl
yeah what is it
she was a young guy you find the beer
out you should have twenty girlfriends
and she's just flirting and I go no I go
okay would you go on a date with me and
she goes in a [ __ ] heartbeat Dom
you're full of [ __ ] couger she goes try
me see you girls try me
119 I wasn't even drink yet leave the
[ __ ] she had on like a like shorts or
something she goes trying me and I go
what do you mean and she grabbed my hand
and put it on I like [ __ ] and she goes
so what are you gonna take me on a date
that was like Todd night you know what I
took it like a bar yeah I took it to a
bar like a country-western bar in
Carbondale hmm like a gentleman and I
was really jetting I'm like
she let me touch her [ __ ] I don't know
what my next step is like I did not know
what my next step was as a man I had
never been involved in this situation
before I was always the aggressor oh I
see that's what I realize I'm the
aggressor well that's a fun position for
a woman occasionally that's why women
love Halloween
well we were eating what we were
drinking she said to me we're gonna have
we started snoring hmm and she goes by
the way I stopped at the pharmacy and I
got a sponge and I go why would somebody
tell me I didn't know what a sponge was
right it's 1983 I'm a dumb [ __ ] I'm a
dumb [ __ ] yeah she knows I got a sponge
so we'll be safe tonight i sat there
just staring at my drink like a little
girl bro like you nervous intimidated
cuz her age I want to come home like I'm
trying to get I was like you last week
trying to get out of it I don't know I'm
gonna get myself out I'm trying to get I
was trying to get all the try to go away
from the other dude I lost so we had to
come more beers then I got more [ __ ]
bumps as she was you ready to go yeah
what she's given a 19 year old who had
the blow you were her she did we cop
hilarious it's like a grab
I mean 19 I was legal o'clock she could
do whatever the [ __ ] you want
oh my god yes you was she took me home
she goes let's go upstairs
we went up her sister was there it was
like nothing there was like nothing
happened we went upstairs we wanted to
into a kitchen area we spoke with her
sister and she doesn't have bedtime you
ready blowing like a gas and she took me
upstairs and we went all night on the
blow and then we became like an item
shut up dog it was like be like JLo in
our little I'll see you tonight
we stayed up the whole night to 8:00 in
the morning I never done that with a
woman before my home I was blown away
she was like you're mrs. Robinson we
[ __ ] we talked we [ __ ] we talked we
[ __ ] that's fine
and then she made breakfast I went
through doors down she went to work and
then every night I would go over that
ten [ __ ] we'd eat and then I moved oh
it's a way I was like thank God I moved
to Snowmass Village which was nine miles
up the valley down the way the Aspen and
I thought that and I didn't tell nobody
like my roommates I grew up with those
[ __ ] why didn't you tell
anybody
cuz in those days I ain't nothing I was
raised I still know nothing yeah yeah
yeah especially against I should he's a
[ __ ] yeah keep your mouth shut where I
come from wait if some [ __ ] God is
giving you [ __ ] then you tell your
friends but one prize she was private
really she was making me do things when
I get that I'm like Mike I make you're
like I believe nobody and then me and it
was four of us so two of us moved in
together and he was my Goomba
I loved the Jimmy Buerkle God rested so
I wouldn't be if it was a friend today
he's the one that talked me into leave
him but it was funny she worked nights
so she would say I'll come over at 1:00
and we'll hang till 3:30 I'll take a
shower and then from there I'm gonna
house I'm gonna work at she would work
at a place called the grog shop see if
it's still there in Aspen the grog shop
the grog shop was a wine store oh that
was like actually one in there you
dropped a hundred what do you want
I think 1983 dropped on Jude it was all
the way at the end in the corner mm-hmm
what was what Street was on Galena I
think it's still there it says
Durant let me check Durant yeah dawg I
know that neighbor like either I love it
so sometimes you give me a car rent in
spring can you give us a GPS coordinates
I thought that they were
it was [ __ ] okay there was a weird
case I mean like now I see old the guys
with girls so then it got to the point
where she would I didn't see her like
for like three days I'm just no mess and
the first day she called me she goes I'm
coming up I didn't even have a phone
like I had to go to the supermarket and
call it hilarious she calls she goes
I'll be up let's have a picnic she's
like why is the Piggly Wiggly coming up
on caller Snowmass Village is this
beautiful it is beautiful let's have a
picnic and I'm like take wake up Jersey
no by the protec of my life a picnics
just code for [ __ ] outside apples and
brie cheese at that time in my life
Jesus Swiss and [ __ ] gobbling a
princess what's - though I swear to god
she brought that off like an airplane
crash she brought glasses she brought
wine and at that age I didn't even
understand that I had to make believe
I'm like but I enjoyed being outside but
that was head time I yellowest my luck
you never did it in the park on a picnic
this was wide open listen I don't matter
Billy's 1983 this was this was Aspen I
could have [ __ ] her on the street
nobody would care there's other people
around me - no Aspen is just a sex boom
families were outside we do love that
there was a little lady the family there
was a little lake and I had a little
bridge and I would eat mushrooms and sit
there by myself inside of the time and
I'll never forget that we went back to
my the apartment and we were doing it in
the shower and my roommate came home
hey you say what the [ __ ] you don't take
her she went to take a piss you know and
Ulsan I'm like what's going on and I
opened my shoulder and he's like oh my
god and he ran out I came out we got
dressed he asked me where he goes how
long has this been going on since April
he knows you never [ __ ] told me oh
there's nothing to tell I got like a
crush on her she got a question on me I
came out no we're doing it we dated
straight till
forty-eight hour how did head you just
moved that was a no-no and I did she was
a white shape dog and on the weekends
the first floor the first two months it
was about [ __ ] I loved being together
and doing blow and she wanted to start
to introduce me to her friends she liked
like do you like you I did not like that
how come because her friends were 30
[ __ ] years old because it hurt I was
there with dirty is all problem I was uh
what was I think at that time I was uh
let's say I was a hot carrier
I made $10 an hour like a hundred hours
a week I'd carry a sack I made cement
about brick walls I [ __ ] was a hot
carrier I [ __ ] had made 400 a week
and my rent was whatever why how could I
go in front of 30 year old women who are
successful well some guys would take
advantage of that and let the woman take
care of them you're a man no you're a
real man she was like a manager up there
she'll ago Volvo take care I've dated
guys that I could tell eventually we're
kind of using me I mean not even younger
guys but you know what's interesting
about the whole thing is that I always
dated older guys always I would never
write that from saying right that's why
though I didn't like that sin any of you
because I listen I believe will happen
I'm not doubting anything but it's so
weird when a girl goes to a rock club at
the age of 15 what do you expect you
think it's gonna happen at the age of 15
I gotta think about all these things
because I got a daughter at 7 and 15 is
right around the [ __ ] corner you know
times are so different she already asked
me the other day if that a girlfriend
goes to a sleepaway camp if she'd go to
a sleepaway camp and are you ready to
[ __ ] sleep away from that she goes I
don't know I try it I go she's never
done it I'll take her home for a night I
won't let her do anything
Joey I won't let her do anything at my
house I offered him this game table he's
like is there [ __ ] juice on it Michigan
I'm like do you think I would [ __ ] on it
and give it to your I put my kid in your
house within a week
come back this is rationalists of sperm
shots are out of that so I sat down with
my friend no I almost never have guys at
my place one only from dating dating
them only if we're dating I let them
come to my house I don't want guys have
my address always go to their place so I
can leave I know about five guys you
told me you [ __ ] in the house
that's [ __ ] no you don't that's five
loads on you know you don't know you
don't you [ __ ] I do probably you [ __ ]
do laundry
let me just place them to you if you
send your laundry could be in a 23 M
you're wrong you know what they will
come back with them you sent know what
do you sheets at 23andme the computer
would blow up they couldn't even decide
what my love life you say the [ __ ]
people believe you don't let's go over
the who's Gandhi yeah let's not say
their names but the one comic I dated
like I love them to death from from New
York yeah yeah the guy I think is crazy
he plays cards one day you thought yeah
that guy dated dated dated and we still
you know would that's been my longest
hard enough thing in my life said well
can you [ __ ] terrorize his homeboy in
the man was sleeping he has done he got
out in front of me and shot a hole in a
wall Bob would wouldn't you if I dated
you know I'm fun I'm nice I'm smart I'm
cute I don't feel a house the comic you
were ashamed of me for dating okay okay
and recently I mean I have am a fighter
the young one ah yeah the one I just
told you about no the young young young
young young one that you robbed the crib
with AB don't you say his name don't say
his name but I don't know you're talking
about I don't think I hooked up with
another MMA fighter your house he came
on your stomach so let's just let's just
put 10 6 s yeah
the MMA fight that's burned ripped away
key I did [ __ ] one bite are you just
like the one Shh don't worry boy no
names no names I'm not I'm not saying
nothing bad um
how y'all a lot of [ __ ] up sperm on
your braces Joey this egg wash yes I'm
gonna kill you separate your two
mattresses smelling today the wizard the
wizard that's it that's bad man that's
it it's like four guys he's got he's got
like he's gotta have some disease of VD
he doesn't tested after him well he's
got some of the Spurs he's crazy
drugs and [ __ ] he does that stuff left
around your house from time to time
people may or may not bring powder over
there Joey there's condom dust there's
nothing in my house like that I just had
it in my own house I might kill you
that condoms when you pull them apart
release this particle until here that
could cause some type of carcinogens for
your lungs of course they will argue
whether that was because the battery is
on them you shouldn't use condoms when
you bang her you [ __ ] raw or you suck
it with a condom are you kidding who
sucks a dick with a condo are you insane
I only use condoms when it's a someone I
know [ __ ] a lot of people because this
is a way I think of it and probably I'm
gonna get that is mean no it's the truth
I'm in the same position what are they
gonna cancel on me this wouldn't do it
Vic me what I know we don't take a point
right we got nothin Aluna to be on
cancelled that's what this is my theory
on condoms that's why this part is so
good that you can't [ __ ] with us no more
I actually said to someone I go Joey is
like unbeatable cuz everything he says
is so offensive that like you're like
what's serious what's not who the [ __ ]
knows like it's all like you're the only
guy who could pull your balls out in
front of me after I told you not to
how I thought it was awesome and funny
instead of non-consent listen everybody
we are comedians okay that's number one
we're coming I was just thinking about a
time where are we going with that point
I was just thinking about I can't
babysit mercy no mercy no it's gotta
walk in there like one of those
breathing she's gonna love my gift
please place them to you first off
there's got to be a bunch of ghosts in
[Laughter]
my house you know why because it's a
[ __ ]
I don't bring millionaires to my house
and I'm most most of guys I did have
money so I'm embarrassed to bring them
in my apartment so I never let them see
it that's what guys like to see your
most miserable when we use a day this
girl needs to tell her what are you
treated like this she lives under a
bridge my places are huge it's just it's
just in a bad neighborhood okay you have
animals like rats no there's a raccoon
that hangs out to your house I gotta go
another good Chinese I'll bring you in
nose Joey actually my place is so cute
ask you know apartment you don't know
actually you know looked at the
apartment with me Bobby Lee went and
looked at it with me before I run it
he's like this place really cute but
then the neighborhood way downhill yeah
but I never [ __ ] him there anyway
listen condoms no disrespect I just
gotta be honest it's like when in your
apartment like people who thought it's
not true at all
this is the problem as people believe
you and now probably like nice guys that
I've talked to well listen to this [ __ ]
and think it's real and then they won't
date me Rogan told somebody I have a
whole phone I'm gonna kill you guys well
there's a hole for a second phone for
hose I don't have that I just have two
phones we have you don't even have a
whole phone you weren't like Batman
flash the [ __ ] light into this guy
with a dick a big black dick goes in the
sky and then you all of a sudden get
illuminated like
I shine the dick for them to come on
yeah they come on yeah that's really use
it it's yours
okay let's talk about this condom things
I'm passionate about this what happened
with Don I think caught here's my
argument for condoms every STD is
curable except for herpes well you have
something says he needs herpes so he's
alright I know tons of you can't just
catch it without seeing the outbreak my
point was gonna be that the only things
that are not curable HIV and herpes
although HIV is very manageable these
days I I don't have it but uh very hard
to catch HIV as especially as a straight
woman and herpes if there's no output
being a catch so basically I'm like why
use condoms pregnancy I know I'm not
gonna have the kid so then why use a
condom the Connors are protected guy not
me Luis last weekend you had unprotected
sex in Phoenix but you have no we don't
wear protection like I could come on
loading in no I won't you coming me you
don't nobody did come on you know pull
out if you want to come me you got a
condom nobody pulls out everybody pulls
out the problem is you're all wrong
everybody pulls out Jackie Lee
Priya Jack two times before you even
yeah I got like four more eggs okay I'm
just trying to help you out here
no in all seriousness um the guy in
Phoenix was prime estate nah I do use
condoms with guys I don't know normally
I mean I don't we don't know I mean if I
don't know their situation like who else
are [ __ ] if I don't know but the
thing is this guy told me you know we
loved you know but he told me like you
know I'm a family guy my kids are here
all the time not bring a girl like he
and I believed him because his place did
not have any sign of women but then
later a monkey oh it was great
okay all night was great it was
absolutely great there's total gentleman
he was a gentleman through and through
which is why it was like even to the end
like when I left in the morning
you walk me out most guys just stay in
bed did he come in your mouth no he
didn't know I he didn't have time so
what cuz he pulled out you know your
stop well not quick the sex wasn't quick
he actually [ __ ] me so long I'm
starting to get offended why does he
come by now this is crazy usually they
come and then they can go a lot longer
again like the second time like you said
this guy [ __ ] me sawing the first time
it kind of made me like was a hammer
uh Matt maybe a little bit I guess that
could be it that's I love buddy I love
your honesty a lot of woman would I know
like I told you guys I had a friend that
that was a freak and I didn't find that
Tony years later for years her claim to
fame was I don't have a boyfriend
guys don't hit on me it came to the
conclusion that for years she was having
two smart tender and the busboy come
back that's a threesome is his way the
stories came out that would just I don't
do it everything this was the only time
I ever hooked up on the road and I would
see her and she would purposely Tommy
him one day a bar a club owner said yes
she was here a couple wishes she did
great but I was a little suspect about
her Friday night I know what happened he
knows she left with some weed guys and
the staff told me some weird stuff
happened I know what happened in Vegas I
don't ever hook up with anyone who knows
anyone ever you can't in a town that
could leave a trail like I don't want
any story behind me ever so if it does
happen which has only happened it
happened there happen with the guy in
Vegas in the hot tub but that guy wasn't
you know that we hung out three times
but like they aren't in any way
associated with comedy the club I don't
want a story are you ready to settle
down well what does that mean kids God
always if I like on this enough with
this I mean I'm sure now the guy I like
listen you gotta give me your [ __ ] a
break let's go I don't [ __ ] Joey doesn't
tell you what happened let me tell you
what I realized the last time I had sex
was with the guy that you say I attacked
which I didn't and that was months ago
David girl for a long time when I first
thought Damon a [ __ ] had a wheel Wang
to it because mine doesn't it tastes
like skittles and then and then after
about two years a [ __ ] changed
completely three it got better the [ __ ]
gets better once it's got not getting
abused enough mine has never been abused
you are gonna ruin my love life was a
beaut I didn't say no about it no but
you said I have to give it a break but
it always has breaks I barely [ __ ]
because when you're home alone you
[ __ ] beat it up oh you mean
masturbating even you gotta give it a
little breather oh I've never done you
hit it with a hand how long no
masturbating
no you told me you got a little clicks
yeah with a hammer I never set out a
little bit you said one time you did we
that you why is it so hard for guys to
find yet Clint and I said not mine
you have a little skinny monkey it's
tough to go deep in John find that
little shiny clam he's wrong I was
actually wearing overalls in Orlando and
I put on a little weight and I had a
really bad camel toe and a guy came out
to me and said Joey's wrong you don't
need to lose any weight in your [ __ ] to
me in the audience weight you gained a
little bit of way to win down there no
but like the it made the pants tighter
Oh see so he could see camel toe so then
he said that this is why I stay like
this guy things are going actually kind
of good with this dude I like and now
he's gonna listen is frogger podcast and
Balibo listen of course he's gonna
listen he's not well he's not now I'm
gonna make sure he doesn't know these
people know going in know what that
you're a [ __ ] animal the rule I'm an
ant here's the deal I am an animal and
I'm a freak and I like fun adventurous
sex but I'm not promiscuous there's a
difference I know I always tell stories
on here but that's because we want good
stories but that's my only story from
like the last six months I even told
this the three didn't tell me
this always treats the last three guys
had sex with let me think there's always
a by the way with nobody right over I
don't before that guy it was the hot tub
guy every time we come here it's like
I've [ __ ] one more dude before that
the black dude in Vegas who you puked on
that's the hot tub guy oh that's way
long ago please two years ago well what
the [ __ ] we're talking about it he was a
supermodel that doesn't count I don't
count that that is an achievement you
know something when I'm like sixty now
it sounds harsh but if I'm 60 and I'm
like I [ __ ] this quarterback this
supermodel this is really embarrassing
or is it like wow but it's a list
there's no long oh no I did this it's
been it was it's been a solemn week here
in LA you know and it's gonna be even
rougher towards the end of the week
there was no time for preaching or
talking about your life or re-evaluating
this kind of stuff you know it just
makes you realize that you gotta tell
people you love them you got a look at
people when they leave and ask them
where they gone and so if they do
something god forbid this these are the
ones you hate you know when you look at
your mother right now Kate oh I said
your mother's name something wash my
mama's lupus she's just getting to the
later stage where she gets to be 90 by
the time she gets to be 90 you know
you're waiting for the call the same
thing with you know wish I don't wish to
mean no disrespect anybody at this table
or even listening but when people those
sudden yeah of course it does something
to you it's so hard it's well it's weird
because I was actually thinking about
that I was like it was fascinating to me
because I've met him a few times and it
was like interesting to me how much I've
because I never particularly I'm not
saying anything bad about him I never
I was like he's the greatest guy ever he
was fine but I still was really broken
up when I saw it it still felt it's
interesting how it can affect you when
it's such a shock I woke up in bed and
saw his face and was like what nah I
landed at 9:30 and a lady said get ready
to land I thought we started an hour I
was watching something I was watching
hustler Jennifer Lopez on the plane
course you are and not a fan of her I
just wanted to see if she deserves our
fan of her you sing along to our songs
in the car you sang along what's - JLo
what's that if you have my love Anna is
that her are you saying along - it's
some gentleman I work on the road isn't
it
no I didn't go I have it on tape hello
listen we were I worked with a guy I was
a feature act one time in a condo you
know when you're a feature act crazy
like you this guy was like 40 years old
yeah
he was in very with kids but the first
thing he did that ham was hot which
album that j.lo album the one who's
saying yeah I didn't even know if that
was her with the poster of her she saw -
I know he listened to that out over and
over he would talk about how talented
she was she is she drove me [ __ ] nuts
anyway just put it on because I'll never
watch that movie at home so when the
girl opened up when the stewardess said
will land in 30 minutes the girl opened
up the visor I said to myself [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] foggy in LA oh yeah only
minutes later we'd landed me and Steve
Simone across the street we got in the
car we drove home it was actually so
foggy that night that night I went out
with Pauly
I was driving toward downtown and the
sensor on the car that sense is a
forward collision it kept on saying the
sensor can't work because the
fog I mean it was so bad I didn't know
this so I go put my luggage down there
but Twitter this is Kobe died you know
there's always something I don't think I
was really enough and I called my friend
and watch the Lakers well I went who cuz
I went to Yahoo and it wasn't under the
Yahoo page yet at all but there was
little mentioned on Twitter I called my
friend in his first words where he goes
I'm gonna find out who wrote this room
I'm gonna [ __ ] take a pipe and go
beep yeah no one believed it and I go
get back to me let me know what you hear
and that's when he called me and this is
listening to me buddy this is weird I
had to go to CVS I had to go to
Walgreens and all the sudden tears I
know me too
it was weird it was like every death I
suffered got hit me like this one was
dismal because it's so sunny it's so
such so unexpected that you're just like
wow that could be me and this is the
reaction this is you go back to being
the junk the fat [ __ ] that I was one on
the line to two for five hours
oh my god 2 / 5 you got two and I was
ready to pick up the two things I go
this is part of my disease this is who I
am when to cheer I had it was either
drugs and then it became the food this
is who I am and I go [ __ ] those Oreos it
was you man I'm proud of you no no don't
be proud to figure out that you but I'm
57 years old
plenty I would have been looking like $1
for some people never figure it out but
it was so weird out at that moment I go
that what should I use not interesting I
had this you would call me in those days
and say something like the day we
weren't to Vegas together huh and we got
the call that Brody died don't make us a
common way to god that like I went back
to the room and chase land encore
I wasn't worth it damn he'll come right
back to it I go come cuz we got food in
the room we had a food there and already
left food for me I didn't want to eat
alone
like I called Kenny okay do me a favor I
never really want to ask you come over
to my room and a huge room they're not
free make me cry thinking about it game
over and Brett you know we were friends
and nobody really brought a Brody we ate
I it was awkward it was weird because
because I try to avoid it after me away
client again no that show you had to
change your flight because you got an
audition or something came up you had to
do in the morning so you change your
flight you go to the bathroom you change
your flight so I was there for like two
hours and I've never lost I the only
person ever lost like that was my
grandfather that was sudden he had a
heart attack he was pretty young but I
never my grandfather was a little
estranged I never lost someone that
close that I just talked to like two
days more like it was I mean I mean that
was everybody's had that happen I guess
but the first time that happens to you
it was just so I couldn't get my head
around it I couldn't stop crying I was
like how we gonna do the shows I'm
hysterical and then you came in and then
you deal with it so different cuz I
remember I don't even even know this but
like you didn't say anything about it I
didn't want to talk I know I know I know
I knew because I know myself started but
do you know that we did Vegas and then
we did Tucson and then flying from it
was either Vegas if you find from Vegas
to Tucson on the plane you started
crying but you didn't say a word
but you put your hand on me and I just I
knew that that was like you finally let
it show that show was so hard I couldn't
do that that Vegas show that first night
it was dedicated to him but there was to
go up there and try to be funny and like
and don't get me wrong folks it's my job
it's our job but also 20 years that
venue is the worst one for that because
it was a pitch black it was a spotlight
and you couldn't see one person's face
so there wasn't even like another few
minutes
I like that that's how I do
two summers I wanna see nobody's face
nice I didn't want them to look at me
breakdown
I wanted to see their faces so I wasn't
like in a voile and when I said I
dedicate this show to Brody as I turned
the tears were gonna fall out but I
didn't want people to see me cry and
then we went to Tucson I avoided even
going into my head I know I was starting
to be like is he gonna bring it up at
all no sorry what the heat we did
whatever we smoke pot we did the show
when I got back to the room that night I
broke down and I broke down because I
didn't break down like I was supposed to
on Friday I cried on the plane by myself
but I was sitting there people were
starting to watch me no one knows like
on the plane they were the two people
next to me looked at me and told myself
and then once I saw you that Sunday
because for me death that's it so
surreal no it's so in layers like I'm
just starting to come to grips like a
couple weeks ago they did I asked Lee
about something I think those well Steve
somebody's doing that summer program
what the [ __ ] are they doing for Prodi
well his anniversary's coming up in two
months number one number two I'm just
starting to like his phone them is still
in my face I just don't follow him on
social media I know that's how you have
to think what eventually I meant to pay
the piper you always have to pay the
piper
I deal I did this with my mother and it
came back five years later the Hartley
so all this dealing you got a deal with
this [ __ ] when it comes to death you
have to deal with what can you do
besides cry it out and right fight it
you're gonna have bad days you're gonna
think about them it's the weirdest
[ __ ] thing because like every time
when I'm at the light at Starbucks
avoid it I try to get into the song I
thought it would I think of him every
time I see that billboard behind pink
dot where he had is when you go upstairs
to [ __ ] belly room they got that
picture
I know comedy and somebody punches you
in the [ __ ] before you go up the
stairs
pictures never
time I get upstairs I got [ __ ]
anxiety that picture is huge
bigger than I've wanted somewhere else
because I think the same go to a back
bar to have a drink and to talk to your
friends or get a slice of pizza I think
I love to bake your Brody right there
it's why I love but it just takes it
true every time you're having a great
[ __ ] somebody jumping their titties you
go down and you feel that string and you
go god damn it just blew 160 does that
really happen this [ __ ] ever I was born
guys I always warned them before they
call you know like if I call you ain't
going would you like to go to dinner on
a Friday night and you agree to me to go
to Dan Tana's and the way home I go to
reach between your legs a little fuse
you want another truth yes if it's if
it's a date where I would normally have
[ __ ] you and I know that I can't
because my periods that bad I won't go
out with you if we're not going forever
but if it's like a first date and I
wouldn't [ __ ] you anyway I still will
cuz I don't [ __ ] guys on the first date
ever know that you simple feelings I'd
go with a subway the model I knew it if
you think the questioning and the [ __ ]
Harvey Weinstein case is crazy
this he's blond you [ __ ] mine I knew
the model for three years I saw him all
over the place I know but that wasn't
the first time there's always a furnace
it's never as good as the first time
shot day you know what if you saw a hot
supermodel get naked on a stage in a
shower and all the girls are trying to
[ __ ] him I admit I've grown up a little
but there was a time when I was very
insecure because no one liked me I got
made fun of I was ugly I couldn't get
any the boys I wanted so I admit there's
a little piece of me that when I could
[ __ ] the hottest male model in the world
was like oh my god I never cut like I
can't believe I'm gonna get to [ __ ] this
guy and I did so you know what fine
remember why I don't do it often you're
wrong but I have a little list and I
know the numbers I know all their names
I feel guilty you go
for example I see at the store the other
day I bump into for two minutes on my oh
yeah yes you look you look good
thank you now I know what a woman's
going out to do calmly and I know when a
woman is putting another cent of must
that they want dick I did a show that
night that night she wanted day so I
knew this I didn't say there's nobody
really dead you left I hooked you up
with a black dude with the beard he's
got a big dick that dude did for it are
you crazy
that guy might as well look like black
Santa gives you powder you suck his dick
Joey Logano 22 inch dick no you did porn
for years that's all so that's a bit
more reason I don't want to I'm tell us
poor well Aristotle is me when I first
met that duty with the two white chicks
someone kill me now I would go up there
to get cocaine him he would have his
girlfriend and her sister circle his
dick in the afternoon you know how many
times I'd walk in like a whirl you and
he goes in the couch but don't come back
here and Baldwin would be in there and
assist the girlfriend was really pretty
but the system's kind of ugly and she'd
be naked he would make both the sisters
suck his dick at 2:00 in the afternoon I
go dude why I would take him you thought
you're like Kato take this guy home
Cheney's got a 20 inch dick I don't
well I'm you know that's too big I don't
want anything above 10 and that's a
little big listen I'm like you got
married the couple of Fort Lauderdale I
set them up I set up three couples right
now the happily married I set up I see
and I know what do you think about my
little crush guy to young who the
fighter I told you about he's a
sweetheart he's a sweetheart but he's -
he's not for you the dude you need need
it was bred from BJJ that's what you
need Brett was a nice guy brent is a
nice guy I love him he's adorable
from heaven Cupid shine I want to both
your hearts you what the other direction
you want [ __ ] you want one nights
thing I do not once and I've had lots of
boyfriends I know this is worse than the
law and all that we should be I've only
523 people I could never do a crime week
a because she's only [ __ ] 23 people
actually it's probably 25 25 12 18
months no I haven't but here I'll tell
you truth after the wizard which is two
and a half a month you average no I
don't know I don't know here's where you
forget okay so the guy let's call it a
the comic guy that I actually dated the
longest on/off dude he's my go-to when
I'm in-between guys so what I do is I
date guys I see potential with and I try
not to [ __ ] them until I'm sure you got
like 10 to God to go guys no I don't
have any to go guys I swear to God where
do you keep this you know how many
nights I've been host so last night I
text my buddy Aidan I have a text and I
said I'm so horny right now I would [ __ ]
you and you're gay she leaves I know I
came up to me he also has a freak radar
like me okay he goes Kate Whitney what a
[ __ ] today that's exactly this this guy
that I know that's a friend of mine came
over to me lately goes cake quickly was
very beautiful tonight
thanks but she wanted [ __ ] for life I
know that I call her up she's that I was
in bad no you was yes I was a naughty
boy she was which corrected me she was
going home to text and find victims no I
wasn't she goes oh she's like no I
didn't if Saturday night goes on like
reddit she'll type [ __ ] look at the
big I got power and all this [ __ ] no I
don't I call her up I got you okay she
goes yeah I was worried about it no
problem I kill you the next one I call
that by the way I did nothing I told you
but I did have phone sex with a guy oh
yeah that's right
you're like Harvey Weinstein I feel bad
about the guys man for me I forgot about
that 57 year old man I'm married I have
a daughter and I still like to laugh and
hear a good story and when I want a good
story
friends that fulfill different voids in
my life but think about this when I want
to be depressed I called Lee I won't
give my depression a call we like what
are you doing Lane nothing sent here and
just got back from doing two spots Lee
you know it's 9:45 at night and you're
30 years old go out bug somebody get a
look do something so I have friends that
fulfill different voice like if I want
to feel good about myself I just call me
it's true but when you when I'm sitting
there at 5:00 well I'm sitting there
10:30 suicidal ready to decide whether I
should eat whether I should eat that
next edible like when I'm sitting there
that's 10:13 I'm like should I eat
another [ __ ] and by the way I get my
edibles tonight.thank that I don't wait
I'm getting the 8tx on your brother
Graham somebody's in New York as good as
I've missed the stars of death I need
new I want some what well I'm feeling
that depressed I'm like I should be
doing some in my life I got married I
got a kid I call Lee because I know
because he's doing such more calls me I
don't have a story and then your if I
don't have a story he's like what
happened to my cake with wait but then
when I do have a story is like you gotta
stop book what do you there settle down
quit [ __ ] [ __ ] the wrong people
I don't always I'm getting better listen
after the wizard there's only been two
after the wizard there was a guy in
Vegas the one guy did you do a cleanse
did you go see a Santeria priestess I I
actually went to a shaman after the
Wizards jim Florentine said I'm gonna
have to get us a chicken it's a guy that
got already lying sober yeah he helped
me when you [ __ ]
it's done I got tested I was fine
because like I said nothing is really
important and I've never had an STD I've
only had one yeast infection my whole
life my pussy's very clean it tastes
good
you know what summer's eve all the
vaginal scrub the best [ __ ] ever
submission it tastes like skittles for
what you use it I used to use it years
ago that was on the road I wanted my
balls to be in tip-top Magoo at all
times and from [ __ ] chicks your
helmet smells weird it gets a weird
smell to it and yeah but like a [ __ ]
and one day I was on the road with a
girl that we had a share a condo a condo
and I didn't have any so social the
other thing I had was the summer's eve
graduated bomb loved the [ __ ] ant out
yeah washing myself it's not my whole
body and I wash my balls real good of my
dick let me tell you something my balls
would never that shiny yours dad
that [ __ ] is amazing I I spent summers
ease yeah if you're a man and you want
to get your balls lick with no woman
making faces nothing get some is Eve
agile scrub that and combine that with
manscape the root river love revitalizer
for your nutsack women will love to
[ __ ] suck I even carry the summer's
eve you'll think why fourth of July
every day do you
yeah cuz just in case like then you have
it because the thing is it also for men
it's different but for women it actually
regulates your pH balance so you stay
the way you're supposed to smell so you
know i was i mean honestly like a guy
even said to me i like when i started
using them a girl recommended it to me i
started using them a month later this
guy goes down he's like you're the
best-tasting [ __ ] I was like wow
summers he if like it works uh let me
tell you something you've done a lot of
podcast monday can I say one thing what
can I say one thing the reason I had
phone sex is because I was horny and had
no one to hit up which just want to
point out ruins your theory that I have
a bunch of this guy was like out of town
tell me that you didn't call everybody
you
before you do so is it anyone right now
there's only one guy I can hit up for
sex I guarantee if I go to you I don't
have any eight guys in town you're the
type of [ __ ] that I call nine-one-one
to report a fake privacy to suck the
cops dick that's not a bad idea did
tweet that once that's a bad idea I did
that's a fairly seeing a few things like
fire monkey you're like my UPS guys
adorn your robot with one pin hanging
out nah I don't [ __ ] strangers I'm
telling you I got a UPS guy I didn't
[ __ ] him he's askew what are these dates
you got on the books
Oh Road dates I thought you meant like
dates Road dates actually I've got Oh
Valentine's Day I'm doing Kansas City
I'm so excited and it's free I'm gonna
do comps for single ladies on
Valentine's Day so you don't Friday and
Saturday Thursday Friday Saturday cancel
it in comedy club blue Club yeah and
then I'm in Edmonton in March and kya
and Akron Ohio
I'm happy you could add some happiness
today because I wanted a complete
different podcast people need it right
now I wanted to go off the rails today I
don't want if I can get acid and all
that [ __ ] if I don't have to do some
[ __ ] this afternoon I would have [ __ ]
got something angel dust animal
tranquilizers I would have gone down
some [ __ ] Road but I got
responsibilities I got spots no I know
it's done yes bye it's never too late I
got spots at spot tonight by the way
thank you for giving me the heads-up on
that one gig anyway let me talk to
people real quick about something before
we even get the [ __ ] out of here
valentine's Day is around the corner
what are you single you're not listen
can you imagine finally you're gonna
date and pull your pants off when you're
underway look like they've been through
[ __ ] hell you got skid marks
looks like somebody shot a musket at me
ever see the men next time you judge a
man look at their underwear is
disgusting I have a rotating stock of me
on these why cuz over the years they
kept sending them I got roll I got
everything I got red ones green ones
what colors do I have on today let me
see you let me see you [ __ ] flag take
them oh my god they're so cute they're
flowers
oh yeah I love ain't [ __ ] around here
today that's what I do for manscaped I
love manscape yeah it's me undies I love
me undies anyway me undies right now has
matched you underwear for you and your
girl for Valentine's Day they got lots
of special prints for you to get in the
mood for Valentine's Day if you don't
have a special someone me and these has
some even better if you got a dog and a
cat they can match them too with me
undies all right take poor buddy band
bands and Anna's made from their
signature micro mode all material so
your dog could look just like you that's
man's best friend for a reason plus me
undies has [ __ ] everything socks
loungewear joggers robes slippers even
baby clothes personally I'm in all on
the joggers you know that because you
know how much your [ __ ] uncle Joey
loves comfort and these things are
comfortable is [ __ ] they hold you nuts
perfectly if you never sweat them I
could I could smell my balls at 9
o'clock at night no wow wow you should
make a ball candle I'm Mellie right the
house you and your little buddy
your little bed bugs and your bed to
slip them anyway I love [ __ ] me on
these speaking I love me and these are
showing you the love with a killer offer
for the church family you ready go to me
on these calm slash Joey I'm gonna give
you 15% off and free shipping on your
first purchase plus you get me on these
100% satisfaction guarantee again grab
your pen that's 15% off and free
shipping you and your girl for nice
matching underwear come on who's better
than you and if you show up there Tempe
improv that weekend and pull your
[ __ ] pants down I'll send you a shot
of [ __ ] tequila right there from the
stage how's that matching me underwear
for you and your woman what are you
[ __ ] nuts that's what me undies does
for you go to me on these calm right now
slash Joey and get 15% off alright one
more time me undies comm slash Joey 15
percent off for your first purchase free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
and slip into some
uncomfortable and those [ __ ]
shitstain pieces of shake it got out
women smell those when you go to the
bathroom you know that when you're naked
you go to bathroom
or what I'm gonna reach over and smell
your underwear to judge it and they have
every right to [ __ ] question
you filthy [ __ ] legally undies
what was the song of the day today
Kashmir Kashmir by Led Zeppelin that's
as long as a day
listen Tempe weekend Valentine's Day
weekend the party starts on 13th
Tempe improv and then February 29th I'm
its [ __ ] Treasure Island get
your tickets now that's it and that's
that I want to thank my favorite sister
in the world who was like [ __ ] I gotta
say I gotta call Harvey's attorney to
lie together in the mix I love you too
thank you very much for being a guest
say cuz I wanted happiness in here I
don't want to drag a [ __ ] dog in
Italy I was in the mood I just wanted to
laugh and giggle and act like an [ __ ]
and I hope you guys enjoyed it flying
jus I love you little brother how easy -
well it was a 75th anniversary yesterday
of what those [ __ ] evil [ __ ] up his
did to your tribe and I was [ __ ]
embarrassed I was sitting on the couch
crying [ __ ] old Nazi [ __ ] I
hope they all burned and [ __ ] hell
anyway I love you guys doesn't Joey Diaz
dotnet and get you to a dates and that's
it I'll see you next week enjoy your
Wednesday you loved that was fine